[Music]
in what's next news what's next
submitted by Brickhouse she's mighty
mighty badass she's she's a she's
stacked stacked
yeah like a like a square like like it's
Maximus is a huge compliment because I'm
gonna shaped like a square spongebob
high school high school removed as
cafeteria chairs to make the students
study more I don't understand how about
logic word no it's Asian as [ __ ] China
North Korea Asian as [ __ ] dude wait how
does that help they're studying I'll
give you that that is anything yeah I'll
give you that because if the whole thing
is like sit on the floor right Oh some
countries and some restaurants some yeah
some restaurants and countries but I
think any time any time where there's no
clear logical explanation that's Asian
Chinese wait do they give them standing
like it's lunch tables then cuz like how
are you gonna eat when you like you're
standing up I don't think we could
decipher it with our mind I think it's
just one of those things where like you
have to eat crickets because it's gonna
help you study more like that so you
guys are right this does take place in
China and this school thinks that by
removing cafeteria chairs it will
motivate the students to eat faster and
dedicate more of their time to study I
believe that you only need 10 minutes
see oh my god Wow for the Chinese
workforce the absolute opposite of like
Italy or something or like I don't do
now you know or like yeah every country
that had this yesterday this is the
cafeteria oh no there's still like
pretty low yeah that's amazing
I mean you know what I would do is just
I will go to the corner and squat or sit
oh yeah
I'm still on the table yeah so then
they're saying that next they're gonna
designate a lunch spot at a table for
everyone to eat standing and the rest of
stuff they should only be spending ten
minutes
on lunch that should be nothing that
they should get back to their studies
sounds like boot camp yeah well they
were saying that um this a lot of people
are thinking that this is inspired by
the day capcal g8o k8o factories what
that is
cow cow cow cow so they're saying that
it's their infamous for using
military-style disciplining techniques
refer students for the Galco cow no but
they need a sister inspiration huh
they're saying that even there they have
charity oh do they do this to kids too
cuz it like none of these kids are
bitchin right like these kids are like
nobody's like nobody's like pouting at
the camera like like they would in
America in America you just see a bunch
of kid in the cafeteria be like my
parents on [ __ ] like is over there is it
like is it part of their kids programs
to like it's hardcore over there I think
it's hardcore because it's survival like
going to a good school and then like
competing is just so different like you
know depending on where you get into
what companies you go into and all that
that's gonna determine the rest of your
life like does their Barney the Dinosaur
only hug them if they did a good job
that day at work they should I think I
think they're Barney what dinosaur like
TV show is only teaching you like
algebra and [ __ ] like there's no work
there's no hugs
yeah no hugs to complete a problem
successfully perhaps yeah maybe my
reason Barney oh yeah it's true with my
TV show I don't know that this talking
cat person
caspere's I am so disconnected from the
baby world oh is it like paw patrol
thing educational it's not
there's little lessons here in there
like don't set the school watch it yeah
I watched it it's pretty nuts man it's
what it's like a see he's like
CG cartooning kind of and it's done by
the same people who did mr. Rogers Oh
Daniel Tiger that's his name oh yeah the
theme song don't listen to it it will
get stuck in your head first nine days
doodle we have the train and everything
yeah wait wasn't he a character in
Mister Rogers neighborhood the tiger was
he yeah he was a little puppet I believe
it I don't remember I just
I remember the trolley scientist I
remember the trolleys yeah Detroit had
attitude for the school but I don't
remember the names and I remember the
weird castle guy that [ __ ] that world
when the train went to the castle world
- it was freaky I'm like why does he
only liked it when the train would go to
like the factory then you could see like
how it's made I love that [ __ ] with all
of the worlds I liked how the the
fictional and the real life kind of
blended together
I like that too but just the characters
like he always had like really pointy
sharp [ __ ] features like cheeks and a
really big job I also like I also liked
the street light you know the red green
and yellow light and it made me want to
have my own collection so anytime I
could Jack a street sign I tried a
jacket if I could or stop signs
how could you mr. Rogers why did you
teach him you know what I took you know
like when there's construction they have
the the orange like light that blinks
are you god I was so jealous dude
because remember in Clarissa explains it
all she had like a [ __ ] stop sign or
something and I was like I wanna [ __ ]
sign all that [ __ ] this is still that's
true cuz we don't know how they got that
I don't know why they blame video games
exactly in everything it's just you show
a kid something cool and they want it
yeah that's true yeah that's cool that
has no chairs in the cafeteria so how do
you feel about like Isaac going into
school with a bunch of competitive like
Asian kids no cuz I mean I
school if he yeah there are a lot of
Asians at school but he too like
gravitate more towards the Latinos yeah
just like all his friends are like
they're still in the same class but then
doesn't he have to work extra hard to
keep up and all that stuff because in
irvine that happened to my nephews
oh well based on because the
back-to-school nights that I've gone to
and stuff like all I could seem like
they're pretty on the same level like no
it doesn't seem like there's like higher
achieving kids there so put your parents
that we always get a weird angle right
that's true you get the clean one you
get the nice clean angle like on the
presentational nights I wonder what it's
like day-to-day in the school because I
remember it very differently than my
parents do you know I mean it's like
Lord of the Flies they think everything
was just really pristine and nice and I
remembered like [ __ ] cupboard toilets oh
yeah
crying kids and you don't say when it
when you're checking in is like how was
school today and your teachers in like
on best behavior to your dad like you
fake-ass [ __ ] you don't smile this
itself yes yeah like like my teacher I
remember my teacher crying a couple
times because I think she was having a
weird time at home and she I don't say
that's my mom yeah go home I just oh
yeah you know I said tell me about a
couple of his teachers that were they'll
be super emotional a couple a couple of
them where they would be really really
emotional during the school day and then
he'll be like yeah mommy you know they
had this uh like they'll hand out cards
if they misbehave like a green card or a
yellow card or a red card or whatever
and then she'll be like yeah she was
just on those cards freeze everyone was
getting cards no geez make sure you had
like she brought her emotions this girl
might be he's the craziest thing you had
a teacher do like during class like not
in front of teachers because I had a
teacher throw a chair once that's not
really like throw it across the room but
he like picked it up and like almost
flipped it he's so mad but the
substitute no he's my I usually use my
Spanish teacher he's super cool she like
like this absurd movie all the film with
Tom Berenger dad that's the mood
he's like he becomes a substitute
teacher because his friend who's a
teacher gets gets like maimed or
something yeah she gets her she broke
Anderson yeah and then he goes there he
goes through the school and then he
stretch throwing kids out a [ __ ]
window
yeah and they made for these [ __ ]
movies for four films of like their kids
movie he like kills a whole football
team yeah it's pretty good like doing a
meth lab or something it's like the most
racist like old-school movie to where
it's like all the stereotypes like play
into it's like a blaxploitation phone
it's the what genre is it it's the it's
the genre of like of like I'm gonna I'm
gonna reach these kids I gotta help
these everybody ends up [ __ ] a ball
at the top way like a gun exactly yeah
it's like institutionalize or some [ __ ]
like mr. Holland's Opus but like like
hood what's that a deliverer yeah yeah
yeah exactly my mom my mom taught me
racism
we're like she would taunt like I would
get in hella trouble to go with like the
whole substitute teacher thing like it's
house racist towards like black kids so
when I was in elementary school we also
had that cart system too you know like
it's like red yellow green purple
whatever and then my mom would always
say like you got a act right you don't
want to be a bad kid like all the black
kids my mom would say that but then I
was like oh it's funny because there's a
guy my class is also a troublemaker as a
black kid and I was like cuz I get way
more carbs than the black kid does
you're worse than the blankets and I'm
like yeah and then so I didn't really
know how to take that as if it was like
a good thing or a bad thing
none of my mom was still racist cuz like
there's that her only kid is actually
more bad than the bucket maybe you were
here to correct your parents like that's
it that was your purpose now look at who
you marry didn't even marry an agent
that's Joe spice still doesn't even know
what Mexican is like for the longest
time my parents didn't even know what
Mexican was they called everybody
Spanish they're like Spaniards they're
like those Spaniards from the south do
they think Oh from the south okay
the Spaniards that live in Mexico yeah
they didn't they didn't know like yeah
yeah and meanwhile I learned braces and
for my parents because my mom like
through an example of a racist thing my
mom when today is uh she'd be like oh
this lady dropped her purse and I'm like
what lady and she's like just so scared
and use the kid is it's the black one
over there right but it's just like just
to say her race is scary Wow
[Music]